what could it be whoa whoa that looks
like a very large helmet and a very
large couple of weapons Alexis what is
this gladiator Hulk armor Wow from Thor
Ragnarok in theaters in a couple of year
times we just revealed this you just got
it in straight from the side
oh my god everybody they totally just
confirmed Planet Hulk for thor ragnarok
so there's a couple twists and I'll
explain the behind-the-scenes stuff that
they showed a comic-con the actual
footage that they showed off a comic-con
for Thor right right like the teaser
wasn't something that they were gonna
put in the movie it might make the DVD
bonus features because it's hilarious
but if you've ever seen the way that
they filmed the office TV show the US
version of The Office like a comedy
documentary style thing they basically
shot a version of that to show what Thor
was doing during civil war just to
explain like he was in Australia he'd
moved in with a guy from Craigslist
named Darryl Chris Hemsworth is sitting
in this really dumpy looking beige
apartment just like I just need some me
time so it was really just this funny
parody video that they shot over a
couple days because they've only
actually been filming on the movie for
about five days so if you didn't know
they finally brought Valkyrie into the
Thor movies which I'm I'm really happy
she's a really awesome character from
the comics so Lady SIF is still part of
the Thor movies but I think there was
some scheduling problems and I think
that they just wanted to change the cast
up a little bit like there's gonna be a
bunch of people that you haven't seen
before so because this is the third
movie they don't want it to feel exactly
like the last movie so I'm totally fine
with that mixing the cast up but the
real big truth bomb that was dropped
like the whole purpose for me making
this video is because they've revealed
that they are doing the Planet Hulk
storyline the people thought they were
gonna do there was a big rumor last year
even the year before that I think when
they were first talking about the movie
that they might decide to do a version
of Planet Hulk inside it because a lot
of you probably know that Marvel has a
problem with releasing a Hulk movie like
they totally want to do a new Hulk movie
with Mark Ruffalo but because they have
some legal issues they're still kind of
tangled up with Universal they have the
distribution rights Disney itself has
the biggest movie distribution network
in the world and they don't want to let
somebody else distribute a movie that
they make so they're just gonna wait it
out but because that would take so long
Mark Ruffalo would be like this crinkled
little old man by the time they could
make a solo Hulk film so they want to
use Mark Ruffalo as much as possible
because he's an amazing actor so they're
just beefing up extra Hulk storylines in
other movies so he's getting like his
own movie spread out over a couple of
different Avengers movies if you've
never seen it or you never read the
comic book storyline Planet Hulk is
probably one of the best standalone Hulk
stories in a long long
time there are a lot of great Hulk
stories but Planet Hulk is just one of
the most cinematic ones like it would
look amazing on screen they even turned
it into a cartoon movie now it was made
for children so they didn't do a lot of
the awesome stuff from the comics like
it gets really hardcore but if you've
ever seen the movie Gladiator with
Russell Crowe it's a great Ridley Scott
movie imagine that with the Hulk
so the Hulk gets armored up he wears
gladiator armor he fights a bunch of
fight he beats the out of a bunch
of aliens so there will be elements of
that in Thor Ragnarok if you didn't know
Jeff Goldblum is also playing the
Grandmaster he's one of the elders of
the universe they did show like a really
short behind-the-scenes video that we
like totally wasn't finished in a ball
of Thor dressed up like Braveheart
charging at Hulk wearing his gladiator
armor in an arena so it seems like the
Grandmaster character is going to have
something to do with forcing this Planet
Hulk storyline so like if you don't know
who he is in the grand scheme of things
in the comics he's kind of this cosmic
pleasure-seeker that's like on like a
vacation cruise just looking for fun in
the universe so beat you know because
he's one of the elders of the universe
he has immense power very questionable
morality and he's a little bit like the
collector from guardians of the galaxy
who's one of the other elders of the
universe so you're gonna see a whole lot
of crazy Jeff Goldblum in this movie
which sounds like it's gonna be so much
fun crazy Jeff Goldblum with the crazy
Loki character just making Thor in the
Hulk fight in an arena the best guess
for where Odin is is either Valhalla or
at the mercy of hell in hell hell is
kind of like Asgard's version of hell
you have to remember that as Guardians
are on a different plane of existence so
the way they experience death in the
afterlife is very different from normal
humans but it seems like Odin has been
sidelined he's being held captive but
Anthony Hopkins is still in the movie so
he'll come back at some point but at the
end of Avengers age of Ultron Thor did
go back to Asgard
to find out what was going on with the
visions that he had he started to have
visions of the infinity gems but he
didn't really understand them and at the
beginning of dark world
Odin is explaining to Jane Foster about
the relics that predate the creation of
the universe he's talking about the
infinity gems so Odin knows all about
the Infinity Gauntlet the infinity gems
so it seems like since Avengers age of
Ultron Thor has been
seeking Odin out to find out what the
hell is going on to get more information
but surprise surprise like the last time
we saw Odin he was really Loki so he's
probably dealing with that right now so
it's gonna be really fun to see the
movie addressed you know what happens
when Thor shows up at Asgard after
Avengers age of Ultron and finds out
that Loki is helping keep Odin captive
so where I'm expecting things to go off
the rails like Karl Urban here just
tweeted a picture of this haircut that
he got he just travelled to the set of
Thor Ragnarok he's playing scourge who's
going to be serving hella the person
that Cate Blanchett is playing and she
seems like the point where the movies
gonna go off the rails so let me know
what you guys think about Thor Ragnarok
so far based on what you've heard
obviously they haven't released any of
the stuff online yet if they do I'll
totally post it but because they just
started shooting the movie they'll
probably do more fun behind the scenes
teasers so I will totally post new
videos whenever stuff drops so be sure
to subscribe to get everything but
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Craig gets you and a $20 Amazon
gift card be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details I'm gonna go
ahead and continue the Marvel giveaway
so I'll just say it like new round
starts now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video there's still a couple Marvel
videos but my next video will probably
be Legion of Doom they're doing just to
society vs. Legion of Doom on TV this
year so it is gonna be so lit so I'm
gonna do a trailer video for that next
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my breakdown of the
guardians of the galaxy 2 trailer they
showed off and you can click here for my
breakdown of the spider-man footage
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you